I want to say first of all I was honored
because you had not directed a scene in
quite a long time you came out of
retirement just to direct my scene right
I recognized the inherent talent there
and I felt I must rise to the occasion
well you did we I want to ask you they
were thrilled they spontaneously stood
no one asked them to I got all kinds of
prestigious awards as you probably saw
but what what's most important to me is
were you happy with my scene I was
delighted I recognized true cinema art
when I see it okay what is it that you
liked about my performance what did you
notice did you notice anything in
details that you particularly proud of
the subtlety with which I thought you
and the Sharktopus interacted the two of
you work together I think in a truly an
award-winning perform right there I
really feel like you know that was first
of all we didn't use any CGI which I
thought was impressive right
also III know that you've worked with
you gave so many people their start so
many great talents their start Francis
Ford Coppola worked with you before he
really worked with anyone else isn't
that true yes right as a matter of fact
he he was the sound man the second
assistant director and shot second unit
all on one picture really very versatile
okay and you know then this kid's going
places actually I knew it was good I had
no idea that he was gonna go to the
heights he did okay Ron Howard I think
also Ron Howard his first directing jobs
with you exactly he started with us as
an actor and the picture it was called
eat my dust car chase film it was a big
success and he came into the office and
he said I know you want to do a sequel
whether star plays a role in a
successful film he always asked for more
money
I will star in the next picture no more
money and I will do an additional job
and I said what is that and he said I'll
direct and I said Ron you always look
like a director to me yeah
you influence the way film trailers are
made I think many people especially
young people think that film trailers
have always been similar but no you
really changed the way they were made
with a certain innovation what is it you
did well it was Joe Dante he went on to
become a very well known successful
director who started cutting trailers
for us and he was cutting one trailer
and I looked at and I said Joe is this a
fairly dull trailer what can you do to
jazz it up he said come back this
afternoon
I went back this afternoon and there was
a the same dull trailer in the middle
was an exploding helicopter it made the
trailer answer question was there an
exploding helicopter in the film there
is no law that says everything in the
trailer
that's fantastic the balls man that was
incredible so I mean what isn't what
this show would be jazzed up by a
helicopter crash occasionally you know
that's the kind of thing that would help
a talk show
we know they should do it everywhere it
could give you the stock footage would
you charge me for it
very little
[Laughter]
you've got great titles great titles for
your films one of my favorites attack of
crab monsters and and there's the of
course the title for it as so many
amazing titles over that do you come up
with a title first and then decide to
shoot the film how does it work
sometimes appearances grand theft auto
which was Ron Howard's first film as as
a director the title came first but the
foe the film he did before eat my dust I
forgotten the title we were shooting a
car chase somewhere out in the San
Fernando Valley and dust was flying all
over the place and the director said we
had a call it's Victor eat my dust I
said we will and he said I'm joking I
said I'm not joking that's a great title
so the title came in the midst of
shooting
you